how is Bowman not in jail well the thing
is he was a school principal and he
would never ever now seriousness how is
it that this man committed a crime on
camera how is it that this man committed
a crime everybody saw on video commit
the crime he lied about committing the
crime and Republicans have done nothing
cuz technically it didn't really stop if
it technically I asked the one lawmaker
and he told me nothing to do what I
asked no no I asked one L maker why he
didn't get arrested and he told me
pulling the firearm illegal right yes
but they said because it didn't when he
pulled fire alarm it didn't happen when
they technically was Voting that has
have nothing to do with what I said but
that's what I'm saying that's the only
reason why they they were able to Skid
that that loophole that's what they
that's not a loophole right that's
that's wrong so pulling a fire alarm
falsely anywhere is illegal right I
don't it doesn't matter if you're in
Congress or in a school Jamal Bowman did
it and lied about it the only reason
he's not in jail is because there's I'm
tell you the information they told me
yeah right but that that's that's like
that makes no sense it's like saying why
didn't the guy get arrested for stealing
the sandwich because it was Friday what
the the the location of the capital has
nothing to do with whether or not it's
illegal to pull a fire alarm the issue
is that there are criminals occupying
the government and there are no there's
no good men or women willing to do their
jobs not a single Capital police officer
took it upon themselves to make an
arrest look if a capital police officer
has the ability to arrest someone for
walking you know entering the building
unlawfully like breaking security if a
cop has the ability to issue a citation
for driving of their own valtion if a
cop has the ability to arrest you
because they witnessed you uh
obstructing a roadway a capital police
officer could just walk up arrest Bowman
and say we saw you on camera do it
there's no investigation needed but
there is not a single good man in the
capital police who will actually
criminally uh take it upon himself to
enforce the law yeah and George Santos
was the only one who introduced um
expulsion papers for for J woman what
what is this reality we live in
where it in order for a crime to be for
a law to be enforced you you require
some kind of act of Congress yo if a cop
Witness is someone falsely pull a fire
alarm he will arrest that person no
question anywhere Jamal Bowman did it a
single Capital officer nowhere just said
I'm going to arrest the guy I haven't
looked at in a couple weeks but he did
get some kind of plea deal where he's on
probation he has to court in three
months like there was something that he
got cited right right Fair Point Fair
Point you got to slap on the wrist then
right at but that was the thing he pled
to this plea it came out whatever else
he released a statement being like I
basically did nothing wrong but of
course I respect whatever and then the
evidence came out that it wasn't just
that he pulled the fire alarm it was
that he removed the signed saying don't
use this door or whatever and then
pulled the fire alive lied and that was
sort of where I wanted more fur from the
Republicans but I guess again they're
chihuaha and again the Republican that
introduced them has now been expelled
from Congress it's kind of crazy it
doesn't really make
sense uh but again like at a certain
point there's the lack of follow-through
like you're kind of looking to this with
the Border stuff like the Republicans
need to see things through to the end
and I just don't know that that's what
they're going to do they need to stop
barking and start fighting yeah it's not
now time is like game time to start
being like Trump like if you really want
to like back your action you've been
barking we had the most embarrassing um
Republican Le house and Congress to have
the least amount of bills passed last
year you know how much times that going
to be used against Republican I mean
used against Republicans this year for
the House Seats but the only say they
should have done more stuff cuz I don't
feel like they didn't pass a lot of
bills first of all is that necessarily
awful like I mean it looks bad the the
headlines looks bad the headline looks
bad but like in effect do we want the
government to just be continuously
passing tons and tons of bills more than
the year before like I don't necessarily
only Bill they passed was like changing
the post office name and add adding a
new Street that's what I'm saying like
they were the least productive Congress
in the past couple decades that's
actually a good thing right but I'm
saying they can't say that like we've
done this we've done this we've done
this they can't point to the record they
can't did nothing we don't want them we
don't want them to pass bills we want
them to pass like referrals right but
I'm saying like you can't say like we
did this we passed the most baned
security bill ever we done this we
helped pass Ukraine a we help pass
Israel Aid like you look at all the
Republicans they made all these videos
for like
Christmas they P they passed it in the
house but didn't it's not going to go to
the Senate stop taking U stop taking
credit for something that didn't happen
but the thing is like it's not that I
don't think I think they should be
productive I think there are certain
things that they should prioritize like
I said with the Border it seems like
they're using it to stop Democrats from
getting more funding out of the country
and also they know ultimately everything
will fail in the Senate I mean it's a
weirdly unproductive time because we're
sort of staring down the the barrel of
another presidential election
Republicans only have control of the
house by a very slim majority I mean
when what's his name uh uh Bill Johnson
the guy from Ohio who just announced
he's retiring in like three weeks when
he leaves there's only 219 Republicans
to 23 Democrats so there's a certain
level of like yes I would like them to
do more on the other hand I don't
actually believe this could be a highly
productive time any just don't make it
seem like it's semantics that you
actually did something when you actually
did nothing you know back up your claims
we need the ones that are like limited
government look we did nothing hooray
exactly I'd rather be like hey Aid bills
how about that but I think there will be
Republicans that can like look I
successfully block the Ukraine
additional Ukraine that is doing
something by doing nothing you have done
something yeah it's I don't want nothing
I I don't just don't want like the the
goal to be like
Congress has to say we passed more bills
than last year because problem is with
the average American it looks so bad if
you're a political guy like us like
we're so into this stuff like we we
cheer the S but then you asked like the
regular Average Joe in America they're
going to be like we pay their Saturday
and they did nothing it just the
semantics look bad maybe I don't know if
all Americans would feel that way though
I mean I think there is enough distrust
of government cuz like we want to look
back at Co when they passed all kinds of
things and said all kinds of crazy stuff
like I think there are there is a
growing distrust of the federal
government where people would say like
maybe we don't want a lot of stuff but
if you tell average American like hey
this was the least productive Congress
just leave it like that there's where
the maybe that's how you just have to
twist one word and then it changes
everything the only productivity
Republicans have the worst
Communications criminal referrals
investigations and
subpoenas but where's it leading to well
they're not doing it won't matter
anyways it's we're coming up in a Time
eventually where nothing will matter
unless either party has a super majority
because everybody's voting on party
lines so often now anyways the hyper
polarization in this country there's
there's a chart going viral on Twitter
showing political ideology by profession
and in the 10 years it's just there's no
middle anymore it's gone and I've been
saying this for all there's no middle
anymore doesn't matter you're left or
your right and that gen Z is proving
this that's what I was saying earlier on
the show like gen Z is also drifting
apart from itself there is a
disappearing moderate class in this
country well remember the it's gone
already the data shows it's gone but
remember the the voting sta ICS which
said like women said the biggest red
flag is if the guy if the guy they might
date supports Trump or Republicans and
the men said like the biggest red flag
is if she's a communist yeah Hey listen
my biggest red flag I'm on the dating
app and he says he's a liberal he has he
she they where what when why but you
know you know what I I realize it's
really funny is that you know growing up
the Trope was that men are sex obsessed
and the meme is you know men only want
one thing it's disgusting and then you
start to realize when you watch comedy
videos it's actually totally the other
way around guys are object oriented and
totally interested in sports numbers
they actually don't talk all that much
about women and women talk about nothing
but guys men have like a lot of like
unique hobbies that end up binding them
together with their friends so I look at
I look at these comedy videos and uh so
I follow a bunch of comedians on
Instagram I get a ton of comedy videos
90% of the of the clips that come from a
guy will be about an issue and like
it'll just be it could be about anything
like you know with uh with Dave
Chappelle look at his jokes he's J
talking about Madison cauthorne uh
handicap he's talking about Andy Kaufman
and Jim Carrey telling life stories all
of these female comedians the joke is
they're always just talking about their
vaginas and so I mean that's a crash way
of for the shock Factor but every single
female comedian when I'm on Instagram
and I hit refresh and I'm seeing all
these comedians I if I if it's a female
comedian I know that if I hit it she's
going to be talking about dating a guy I
know if it's a guy it could be anything
and the reason I bring that up is
because as we're looking at the the
bifurcation of politics between men and
women I believe it's going to result in
this country moving conservative for the
reason of women are more subject
oriented and more time constrained on
having a partner men are not so if a guy
says I don't like commies he just won't
date anybody but around 30 to 35 when
women start getting you know the
biological clock is sticking and they
want to have kids they have to try start
trying to find a guy but if guys are
skewing to the right those women will
have to adapt themselves to the guy not
the other way around yeah okay so you
ever heard of the book uh Men Are from
Mars Women Are from Venus so my one of
my favorite points in that book was the
the psychologist John gry points out
that when men go to lunch they're
typically going to talk about a specific
problem they're like we have a there
there is a purpose to it right they're
they're meeting it's something there's
something to do women go and they just
sort of gather a lot of information
right it's one of the reasons like the
stereotypic because like girls can be on
the phone with their friends for hours
and hours because they're wired to do
different things and I think both are
valuable but they play out very
differently in society like well look at
a family guy has the joke where Peter
Griffin gets injected with the gay
genene as part of uh clinical trial and
then he calls I think he calls Quagmire
and he's like hey Glenn and Glenn's like
yeah what you doing what do you mean you
called me and that just shows you like
the joke of the difference between the
feminine approach to calling someone
versus the guy it's like you called me
what do you want yeah but it's it's just
totally different and I think that you
know these things could be good the
problem is that feminism has really made
it so that women are trying to compete
with men in male spheres they don't just
do things that are natural to women and
like them uh it it sort of makes makes
it so like the best female comedians
that I know actually have some really
interesting social observations right
like when Ali Wong who does talk about
her vagina a lot would talk about trying
to trap her Harvard educated hus or
Harvard business business school husband
it was really funny right because the
way women talk about like the way they
approach dating when it's not
necessarily about their sexual approach
to dating can be really nuanced can be
really interesting because it gives you
an insight into something you may not
know it's the same thing with I I don't
watch female comedians anymore I don't
know why would yeah because dude she's
going to be talking about a guy she
dated and I'm just like all right that's
that's look you ask a random girl on the
street and she'll tell you the same
thing that comedian just said but it's
totally it's totally fine if this is
what women find funny hearing another
woman talk about her boyfriend for me
I'm like you know that's why we we were
talking to the members only show about
this one female comedian who made a joke
about homelessness and I'm like that was
a really really good joke and uh but
it's just like yeah we talked about this
but I I swear I'm on Instagram and I'm
going through it and I'll hit a guy's
joke and he'll be like you know so my
car broke down or something like that
and you're like oh wow what happened to
your car and or I'll be telling a story
like I was going to the supermarket and
this guy was trying to buy this
Coca-Cola right and I'm like oh what's
this story about buying a Coca-Cola
something that happened and then I click
the woman and she's like so my boyfriend
here's the trick my boyfriend I'm like
okay well I don't it's unrelatable to me
and that's fine you're allow to like
these things but anyway aside from all
of that no more winging about female
comedians the point is what I what I
what I've started to see with these
social
trends uh uh when we've Le we've learned
this from Instagram women care
substantially more about social uh uh uh
you fit in socially than men do I think
we've known this for a long time what
this means is a guy will be 35 sitting
there like yeah you know what I I want
to vote for Trump these women don't like
it whatever I guess and these women are
are going to be going I'm 35 and I need
to find a husband but all of these guys
are into Trump what do I do thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time